so it was about the first week that
we've been playing player unknowns
battlegrounds and so he says I'm an I'm
gonna take you to the school
and if you know the school it's
basically like this super hot zone in
the middle of the island we saw a bunch
of other parachutes but as soon as you
get down and hit the ground you forget
where other people are some way before
me and I see them I can see like people
like punching each other there's like
epic fist fights happening I knock out
one guy and then someone out and then I
run around pick up a shotgun okay I
gotta try and find a weapon I see a
shotgun and I like kind of inch my way
towards it all of a sudden this
motorcycle comes just flying in off a
ramp and lands right next to me and as I
come down this hill I see two people
behind a rock healing each other
naturally what are you gonna do I'm
gonna run my car right through both of
them they just I jump out of the house
and I just got run right over and we are
just like all quiet and just listening I
leaned out the window I pop him right in
the head I killed two people and this
fool I got smoked they were only ten or
eight players left there's like 50
people left al-azhar like rolling up
into these houses in a jeep as soon as
he comes around the corner get him right
in the head
[Music]
ask anyone who's played player unknowns
battlegrounds and they'll probably have
a story to tell
selling four million copies in its first
three months of early access
battlegrounds is tailor-made for water
cooler conversations and animated
retellings as people reflect on their
triumphs and failures in the multiplayer
shooter it's a game to spread largely
through word of mouth painting a picture
of an unpredictable highly replayable
experience its rules are straightforward
to be the last person or squad standing
on a massive map with dozens of other
players to put it more simply just think
of The Hunger Games or the movie that
inspired them battle royale despite the
simplicity of battlegrounds sub-genre
there is an array of possibilities
underneath its equal parts terrifying
tense stressful invigorating and
sometimes even hilarious you'll rarely
experience the same match twice it draws
a massive streaming audience for many of
the same reasons of course it doesn't
tell a story in the traditional sense of
the word but in a weird way I think
player unknowns battlegrounds is a
thrilling approach to storytelling and I
think more games can learn from in the
future
first a bit of necessary background Pub
G can be traced through a line of
similar games beginning with the Battle
Royale mod for dayz the survival game
that used to be a mod for ARMA 2 when
dayz became a standalone title battle
royale moved to ARMA 3 Sony Online
Entertainment interested in that type of
multiplayer game created h1z1 and later
developed the idea with h1z1 king of the
kill finally a south korean studio
called blue hole recognized the
potential in the battle royale genre and
created player unknowns battlegrounds
otherwise known as pub G this ancestry
is important because each of the games i
just mentioned exists largely because of
one person brendan green better known by
his handle player unknown he moved from
modding to blue hole spearheading
development on the multiplayer games
that would eventually congeal to become
pub G as we know it now when he first
began his modding career four years ago
green noticed that the vast majority of
competitive shooters were moving toward
the same kind of design they were based
on small maps everyone knew every spot
on the map there was no guesswork to it
when I created battle royale what I
wanted was to create a random game where
you never knew what you might find and
how it was going to end by creating a
massive map Green removed the repetition
of Call of Duty or counter-strike pub
G's terrain villages and coastlines all
remained the same from one match to the
next but it's so massive of a scale that
your perception of it constantly changes
throw in the randomized loot air strikes
and the lethal blue fog that pushes
players into ever constricting
firefights and the map takes on new
meaning the more you play pub G's map
runs counter to something like Halo a
series which evolved over time to
reflect the lane based multiplayer maps
that have become so pervasive in the
shooters face ever since halo 4 I've
remembered those arenas less and less
they become more about funneling players
to a handful of specific places rather
than letting them make informed
decisions on more natural sprawling Maps
my point is player unknowns
battlegrounds gives you time to think it
allows for more intentional choices on
both large and small scales by doing so
it lets you create your own stories
those who have played it can probably
remember very specific details of their
favorite matches what weapons they used
when they ejected from a plane whether
they stuck to the hills or cut through
villages if they were playing as a squad
they might remember just how they
decided to flank enemies you
tactics that started to take shape the
moment they landed on the island this
all contributes to your head cannon or
your understanding of a shared universe
that might not be accepted by anyone
else
Jake Solomon the creator of the more
recent XCOM titles uses this term when
referring to the stories players find
within their assorted rosters of
soldiers
XCOM has a story running through the
campaign in the cutscenes and the
mission progression but it has always
been about the stories that players
create in the moment we're systematizing
the head cannon in the case of pub G
it's the map itself that becomes part of
our individual understanding the
military base in the South may always be
a tranquil place with a useful loot to
me about a foreboding death trap to you
whereas the swamp town outside of Gatka
was the fateful spot of my first chicken
dinner but for you it's merely a small
settlement you only ever passed through
this is the same kind of internal
storytelling that makes games such as
Skyrim breath of the wild state of decay
and shadow of Mordor so fantastic they
are different for each of us and we
experience them in our own way it's why
we seek out live streams and amazing
YouTube moments to see what other people
achieve in this game role we know so
well
it's because sharing these stories is
half the fun which is all to say that in
games like this it's not the concrete
plots we remember but the moments that
emerge from the choices we make pub G
suggests that video game narratives
don't always have to be about specific
characters plot points or guided
decisions and I think more names need to
follow in its wake
more games should be confident enough to
let us be the characters to let us make
our own decisions and to let us create
the stories
and there are like two or three people
left assume that they're all their
friends
unfortunately they came in and I'm sure
that they all communicated and told him
that I was in the car I got got I walk
out I walk and there's two guys just
huddled behind the building together
just like freaked out and I shot them
both in the face we took out about like
two or three more people and then the
schools ours and there's this moment
where even though the match had only
been going on for about like two minutes
at this point and I had like you know
the whole other like thirty minutes left
it's like dude you thought I could do
anything and for some crazy reason we
pulled it off we killed like another
five people Michael did I just kind of
helped and we won and it was the most
satisfying thing ever so yeah that's
that dude over there side it's like roll
behind the rock and bam bam down I got
that chicken dinner man
[Music]
hey everyone thanks so much for watching
episode 10 of reboot this one was really
fun we got a lot of people did gamespot
office involved next week on our off
episode we're gonna do something
different rather than just take comments
about the argument that I had in this
video we want you also to share your
personal stories from battlegrounds or
from like XCOM to or any other games
that I mentioned in this vein of
storytelling we really want to hear it
so we're gonna go through and pick the
best ones kind of try to be as succinct
as possible but regardless just give us
the details and we're gonna go through
our favorite ones and we'll read them on
the next episode a week from today we'll
see you there